so we're here in Chelsea and I've been
lucky enough to be invited to one of
Palestinian chef Judy Kelly's infamous
suppers which happens here at the theme
tonight we're gonna find out just why
she's so passionate about sharing food
with the wider world here with the same
notion that everyone's open everyone
wants to kind of get to know one another
which is really why I just wanted to
have no responsibilities of having my
own place and I just wanted to educate
people about our food and all those
people you saw they were all strangers I
mean there are a few usual suspects that
come every time which is great event and
I don't know anyone they all come
together and they all make friends with
each other or passing then it was a very
I almost felt like everyone knew each
other no they don't there are few that
do but I mean you could tell but within
10 minutes the pockets of familiarity
like expanded yeah and this is the whole
point they're coming to a place with
strangers food that they don't normally
eat and they're all having a great time
thank goodness I mean you can go wrong
but but then they leave feeling like
it's home yeah and we all become friends
you know like the people that you met I
know many of them they all have become
friends of mine through food and through
Palestine and love for Palestine and I'm
so happy for it my
Circle has become bigger and stronger
and better
Judy Keller was born to Palestinian
parents and raised in the UK for her
food is the language of love that has
the power to unite people and perhaps
bring us each a little closer to home
you've never been home right no I've
never been home but I hear from my
parents and stories my mom used to tell
us about her mom when they were in
Palestine so my parents grew up with a
very positive so an image of Palestine
and they wanted us to have it as well
you know we're always represented in the
news quite terribly and there's always
another side as one side and other side
in them as a truce and you know I try to
bring this side of it and people enjoy
it and they are getting educated about
it and they love it and they meet people
and they have discussions amongst
themselves because there are people from
all units some people and everyone in an
English guy sitting next to you had a
Jewish girl and next year on the other
side a Lebanese guy and the Palestinian
guy shows all types of people and they
all coming together eating and they're
respecting the fact that these are
traditional dishes from Jaffa and
concept being at the center of these
connections gave Judy the idea of
hosting her supper club more frequently
now it's on every two weeks in London
where she serves up a range of
Palestinian dishes from her cookbook
Palestine on a plate memories from my
mother's kitchen I got rejected by every
other publisher because of the title
they loved the book they just did not
want the title to have Palestine on it
and I rejected every rejection in the
sense that they said we will consider it
if the title is called you know petals
and honey or I don't know something
different which is great but not for
something that means so much to me this
is resistance this is resistance you
know being silenced and told by other
publishers I couldn't have it if it was
not on this condition I resisted their
options and went and found someone else
but yeah this is home I make us all the
time
yeah seems like a staple yeah like what
are we gonna make we're making something
nah no I saw dishes like my Luba being
labeled as Israeli dishes of the day and
several restaurants in London and it
frustrated me upset me because it's not
even the name a little bit what does it
mean it means flip over flip it's an
Arabic word how can it be an Israeli
dish you totally earlier if there was
ever a nuclear war this is the place to
be this is rubbish you will never go
hungry we have every kind of meat shanks
mince cube chicken look a yeah they
cannot fit what I have food is love you
can see it through the recipes that are
in the book and the events that I'm
having and I just want to sort of put
Palestine on a on a different
conversation where people are respecting
it and enjoying it
I'm seeing that we're actually the same
as everyone else
[Music]